Es ist immer noch ein großes Rätsel.
Wie konnten die Menschen die Pyramiden errichten
- so ganz ohne Bagger, Kräne und andere Maschinen?!
Eine Frage, die bis heute nicht endgültig
geklärt werden konnte.
Wurde eine externe Rampe eingesetzt, waren
es Spezialmaschinen oder sind etwa doch Außerirdische
die Urheber der Pyramiden?!
Jetzt hat ein Archäologen-Team in Luxor Hinweise
im Wüstensand gefunden, die dieses Rätsel
endlich lüften könnten.
Alle wirklich spannenden Infos dazu bekommt
ihr jetzt bei Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier
gibt es täglich spannende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal nur dann verpasst ihr
kein Video. herzlich willkommen!
Selbst heute wäre der Bau einer Pyramide
ein wahnsinniges Unterfangen.
2,6 Millionen Steinblöcke mit jeweils einem
Mindestgewicht von 2,5 Tonnen pro Block müssten
herangeschafft werden.
Mehr als ein halbes Jahrzehnt wären Bauunternehmer
wohl beschäftigt.
Umso erstaunlicher, wie die Menschen vor rund
4500 Jahren diese monumentalen Bauten erschaffen
konnten!
Fest steht nur, dass die Pyramiden extrem
genau gebaut worden sind.
Ungeklärt ist aber dennoch so Vieles: Warum
genau wurden sie errichtet und wie wurden
die schweren Steinblöcke transportiert und
eingebaut?
In den 70er-Jahren des letzten Jahrhunderts
spekulierte der Autor Erich von Däniken,
dass wohl Außerirdische dafür verantwortlich
seien.
Andere Theorien gehen davon aus, dass die
alten Ägypter Spezialmaschinen eingesetzt
hatten oder aber eine äußere Rampe.
In den vergangenen Jahren fanden Forschungsteams
immer mal wieder Hinweise auf die Bautechniken,
mit denen zumindest die jüngeren Pyramiden
errichtet worden sein könnten.
Einige Indizien lassen Rückschlüsse darauf
zu, dass tatsächlich riesige Rampen benutzt
worden sind.
Damit könnten die gigantischen Steine aus
Kalkstein oder Granit immer höher an die
Spitze der Pyramiden geschoben bzw. gezogen
worden sein.
Und diese Theorie wird wohl immer wahrscheinlicher:
Denn jetzt hat ein internationales Forschungsteam
tatsächlich einen Fund gemacht, der diesen
Ansatz bestätigt.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
fanden in der Nähe des ägyptischen Hatnub
nördlich von Luxor die Reste einer ansteigenden
Rampe.
An ihren Seiten befinden sich zwei Treppen
mit einer Steigung von bis zu 20 Prozent - an
ihnen Pfostenlöcher, die ihren Verwendungszweck
mehr als eindeutig belegen.
Hier wurden wohl schwere und große Blöcke
auf Kufen den Berg herauf transportiert, so
die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler.
Sie sind sich sicher: Die alten Ägypter haben
damals die Steine auf solchen Rampen hochbewegt
- und zwar mit der Hilfe von Seilen und einer
Art Schlitten.
Dabei wurden die Seile um Pfosten nach unten
umgelenkt, so dass die Arbeiter darüber die
Blöcke nach oben zogen, während sie nach
unten zogen.
Die Umlenkung über die Pfosten machte es
möglich.
Die Rampe selbst stammt den Angaben des Forschungsteams
wohl aus der Zeit zwischen 2.650 und 2.580
vor Christus und ist äußerst gut erhalten.
Damal regierte Cheops, der Erbauer der berühmten
Cheops-Pyramide von Gizeh, die eines der sieben
Weltwunder der Antike ist.
Dazu Roland Enmarch von der University of
Liverpool: “Damit liefert die Rampe auch
unschätzbare Einblicke in die Logistik und
die Techniken, die nötig waren, um die Cheops-Pyramide
zu errichten”.
Auch Felsgravuren und andere bildliche Darstellungen
untermauern diese neue alte Theorie.
Wow.
Übrigens haben wir darüber zuerst auf dem
englischen Kanal von Clixoom Sciece & Fiction
berichtet.
Wenn ihr also garantiert nichts verpassen
wollt, dann abonniert auch Clixoom Sciece
& Ficton auf englisch.
Dafür einfach hier klicken und noch mehr
Rätsel und Mythen über die Pyramiden gibt
es hier: “Myths, Legends and Speculations:
The Eight Most Exciting Pyramid Facts” Einfach
drauf klicken und ich freue mich auf euch
auf dem englischen Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!